welcome to the show everybody
broadcasting now from a beautiful hotel
well not that beautiful but from a hotel
in Atlanta in any case and I was
speaking at a church yesterday and that
was a lot of fun great turnout talking
about my book Church of cowards which
comes out on February 25th but you can
pre-order right now go do that right now
I demand on amazon.com
that's a Church of cowards again
February 25th is when it comes up so did
you guys catch the the Oscars last night
I can tell you that I I well I was at my
my event for a good part of the night
but I came home I I did turn it on for
maybe 90 seconds in the hotel and it was
just in time to hear an adult person
Sigourney Weaver stand on sage stage and
this was this was right I've turned it
on right at this moment perfect moment
for me to turn it on right at the moment
when she said that said the sentence all
women are superheroes and then everybody
applauded now if you want to understand
how utterly vacuous and meaningless a
statement like that is just just imagine
how it would sound if you said it about
men okay if you said all men are
superheroes everybody would say what
what do you mean all men are super what
does that even mean what are you talking
about obviously some men are great other
men are atrocious human beings a lot of
them are sort of mediocre case in point
there's nothing about being a man that
automatically bestows virtue much less
heroism and the same of course is true
of women this is to say nothing of the
fact and you know I'm gonna what I'm
gonna say next you know where it's going
but I can't resist its to say nothing of
the fact that nobody in Hollywood can
even define the word woman so any
statement they make about women is
inherently without substance by the way
if all women are superheroes Andrea
Yates superhero Eva Braun Eileen Warren
the serial killer Bloody Mary
superheroes huh all of them superheroes
but of course the thing is we know that
you can mark it down remember all of
this girl power stuff the moment that
Trump nominates Amy Kony Barrett for the
Supreme Court which probably now will
happen in his second term when that
happens remember all this girl power
stuff because it's going out the window
it's getting chucked out the window from
the from the 50th floor and it's it's
tumbling all the way down to the to the
sidewalk and it's gonna shatter into a
million pieces it's it's just it's gone
speaking of female empowerment at the
Oscars Natalie Portman and you know I'm
serious about this Natalie Portman I
know I've been critical up until now but
Portman made one of the boldest and
bravest statements I've ever seen anyone
make at the Oscars or anywhere else
period in life I'm stunned by they will
build statues and and monuments to this
moment history books will tell of this
moment folk songs will be sung I was up
all night thinking about it I'm gonna
tell my kids about it my grandchildren
down through the generations people will
be inspired by this I want you to take a
look watch this
I wanted to recognize the women who were
so don't wait wow-wow-wow
[Music]
she embroidered her dior cape with the
names of female directors who had not
been nominated here's the thing when I'm
wearing my $30,000 Dior cape
custom-designed it never occurs to me to
embroider a socially conscious message
on it and honestly if it did occur to me
I don't know if I would have the courage
to do it I'm stunned by it I am blown
away I don't even know what to say I but
but unrelated I was thinking about this
totally unrelated but considering
Natalie Portman finds some way every she
does this every year at the Oscars where
she complains about women directors not
being recognized so if I were to look at
her IMDB page let's say not that I don't
trust her believer or anything of course
believe all women but and I were to
check her films will I see that she's
solely or at least mostly works with
female directors as someone who's so
concerned with making sure that female
directors are elevated and amplified and
lifted up and recognized you would think
that she would make a point of working
with female directors right so let's see
I mean I got the page right here look
let's let's just take a look and I'm
sure we're well I'm sure we're gonna
find that Natalie Portman is is is true
to her word and has the courage of her
convictions I'm sure we'll find that
I've other competence so looking at her
ID IMDB page this past year we'll see
this past year she made a movie called
Lucy in the sky
male director okay
the year before that she made a movie
she was starring in a movie called Vox
Lux male director before that she
started movie called annihilation male
director before that she starred in
Jackie male director before that Jane
got a gun male director before that a
movie called
a tale of love and darkness here we go
female director you got to go all the
way back to 2015 but she did see there
you go female director and that was
was that that was Natalie Portman oh
wait she directed that herself
so in fact in five years she starred in
one female directed movie and it was her
movie that she directed maybe you can't
accuse her of not supporting female
directors it's just that the only female
directors she supports are herself I
mean it's almost like Portman herself
when it comes down to it likes to be in
movies that she thinks will be good even
though almost all those movies I just
named all for crap but movies she thinks
will be good and work with directors who
she thinks will do great work regardless
of their sex it seems like for her
professional life she judges based on
merit and not sexual organs because it
would be actually very bizarre it turns
out and demeaning and dehumanizing to
say to a woman I don't think your work
is necessarily all that great I don't
think there's anything necessarily
special about you as a person but I'm
gonna work with you because of your
reproductive organs you have a vagina
and so that's why I'm I'm on your team
see Portman isn't gonna say that to
somebody
nobody would because it's crazy it's
completely crazy and yet feminists
expect the rest of us to operate this
way they don't but we should even though
again they don't even actually think
that reproductive organs have anything
to do with sex anyway so it's all
confused okay now here's something
that's not confusing fairway is a
family-owned grocery chain and a top ten
employer in Iowa that's been in business
since 1938 and they have over 11,000
employees they service five states with
brick and mortar locations before before
launching fairway meat market to service
the rest of the u.s. in December 2018
fairway announced a new plan to help
eligible full-time employees pay off
their student loan debt so we're talking
about free market solutions to these
problems that's what fairway is doing
this adds fairway stores inc to the
roughly 4% of companies across the
nation that offer employee benefits
concerning student loan debt but let's
talk about the most important thing
about fairway as far as I'm concerned
and that is meat
the fairway meat department has always
been considered the backbone of their
operation what customers can expect from
fairway meat market.com
is hand cut by fairway employees to
ensure the best possible quality it's
the same quality they promise at the
counter and it's delivered right to your
home
the guys at fairway were generous enough
to send me some some product and it was
first of all to get home after a long
day's work not that I have a real job
but for most people to get home after a
long day's work and find a big big ol
box of meat that you can't ask for
anything better than that
that brings a smile to your he brings a
smile even to my face and I only smile
about two or three times a year I have a
dog scheduled on the calendar so we had
different cuts of meat that they sent us
different different steaks different
cuts of pork and it was all delicious I
especially love the sirloin and listen I
know what you're thinking you're
thinking Matt okay you love the meat but
you're a brilliant chef you chef you're
one of the best chefs of our generation
was the meat great because of your
culinary genius or is it because the
meat was actually that good and the
answer is both but I think the meat is
so good that you'd have you you'd have a
very hard time screwing up screwing it
up even if you're not a great chef like
me fairway meat markets quality meat
comes straight from America's heartland
premium beef all-natural pork raised by
family members and sourced straight out
of corn country so you got to get this
this week my listeners can get the
heartland package valued at two hundred
and thirty dollars for just $99.99
that's over half off on this two hundred
and thirty dollar value for $99.99 plus
free shipping when entering Walsh at
checked out the Heartland package
includes eight 8-ounce all-natural
boneless pork chops six eight ounce USDA
choice ribeye steaks which are delicious
one mouth-watering side dish loaded
potato baked gourmet cheesy corn or
brisket baked beans that's more than 50%
off the best meat in America plus free
shipping that's fairway meat market.com
promo code Walsh and look for the
heartland package all right I'm gonna
move on from the Oscars but one other
quick thing walking Phoenix won Best
Actor for Joker and I think it was well
deserved
the extraordinary performance but I want
you to imagine first of all how how
jared leto feels right now because jared
leto played Joker in Suicide Squad which
was an abysmal movie and so think about
Jared Leto okay
the guy the guy who had his role before
him wins an Oscar the guy who had his
role after him wins an Oscar and really
when you think about you think about the
Joker character on film almost everyone
who's portrayed this character has ended
up with an iconic performance Jack
Nicholson - Joker iconic even Mark
Hamill's Joker in the animated series
iconic Heath Ledger's Joker Oscar winner
Joaquin Phoenix Joker Oscar winner Jared
Leto's Joker employee of the month at
Hot Topic that's I think that's the all
he won that stuff that's tough for his
self-esteem
but anyway so Phoenix got up there after
winning and launched into a lengthy
lecture that I can't even play for you
because I think I think it's still going
on as we speak but here's just one
snippet of that that caught my ear
listen we feel entitled to artificially
inseminate a cow and when she gives
birth we steal her baby even though her
cries of anguish were unmistakable and
then we take her milk that's intended
for a calf and we put it in our coffee
and our cereal I have to say I really
wasn't expecting to hear cow
insemination mentioned during the show
but here we are and I want you to think
about vegans think about a left-wing
pro-abortion vegan which presumably is
what would describe Joaquin Phoenix I
don't really know I'm assuming he's
probably not pro-life doesn't strike me
as that but who knows many vegans are
Pro horses I only point is for
pro-abortion vegans their actual
position is this that it is a greater
moral tragedy to drink milk than it
to crush a baby's skull in the womb that
isn't the actual position of
pro-abortion vegans but nice nice speech
and nice performance anyway well I don't
know if I'd say nice speech but
entertaining for walking Phoenix now
moving on I have look I've got no dog in
this fight really and usually I don't
care about political ads or take any
time to analyze them but I didn't want
to take a look at this Joe Biden is a
swinging and flailing as he goes down in
flames kind of doing the same thing to
trying to do the same thing the Buddha
judge that Chris Christie did to Marco
Rubio in 2016 where he knew he was going
down but he's gonna take Marco Rubio
with them and that's what seems like
Biden's trying to do I guess because
Biden is eight hundred and seventy-three
years old and Budaj is 12 and so Biden
as this ancient man is I guess figures
there's some symmetry to it he's
thinking look if the oldest guy is going
down then so is the youngest guy so he
released this ad that people on social
media seem to think is devastating to
mayor Pete I really disagree but watch
this Barack Obama called Joe Biden best
vice president mark has ever had but
Peabody Judge doesn't think much of the
vice president's record let's compare
when President Obama called on him Joe
Biden helped lead the passage of the
Affordable Care Act which gave health
care to 20 million people and when
park-goers called on Pete Buddha judge
he installed decorative lights under
bridges giving citizens of South Bend
colorfully illuminated rivers both Vice
President Biden and former mayor Buddha
judge have taken on tough fights under
threat of a nuclear Iran Jill Biden
helped to negotiate the Iran
and under threat of disappearing pets
Buddha judge negotiated later licensing
regulations on pet ship scanners both
Vice President Biden and former mayor
Pete have helped shape our economy Jill
Biden helped save the auto industry
which revitalized the economy of the
Midwest and led the passage and
implementation of the Recovery Act
saving our economy from a depression
Pete Budaj revitalized the sidewalks of
downtown South Bend by laying out
decorative brick in both Biden and Buda
judge have made hard decisions despite
pressure from the NRA Jill Biden passed
the assault weapons ban through Congress
then he passed the Violence Against
Women Act and even when public pressure
mounted against him and former mayor
Pete fired the first african-american
police chief of South Bend and then he
forced out that african-american fire
chief - we're electing a president what
you done matters
after that video was released one of
Biden's campaign staffers tweeted
gloating that the video has more views
than the population of South Bend and
see that's exactly the problem this
whole thing has a very has a real sort
of I'm an important DC guy and you're
just some bumpkin yokel mayor energy to
it and that's exactly the wrong kind of
energy that you want to bring into a
campaign what's the point of this ad
really aside from the racism accusations
at the very end that are sort of tacked
on at the end because I guess Democrats
are not capable of making an attack ad
against anyone without accusing them of
racism so you have to add it at some
point and the very even if even if it's
just at the end hey by the way PS he's
also racist but before that the rest of
it is essentially mayor Pete is an
attentive mayor who took care of things
that the folks in the town care about
like putting lights under bridges and
fixing the sidewalk devastating
whoo-whoo devastating this ad this ad
could not be any more tone-deaf than if
it was about a female candidate and it
said like while Biden was was saving the
world this woman was changing diapers C
attack candidates for not doing their
jobs don't attack them for doing their
job on the basis that the job they did
was petty that's that kind of attack
never works especially when old people
vote okay Joe Biden should know
something about old people old people
vote and old people are exactly the ones
who get fired up about local issues like
bad sidewalks and a lack of proper
bridge lighting I've been to town halls
I know this so what is this ad saying
it's saying it's saying not just that
mayor Pete is a young whippersnapper it
hasn't done anything important it's that
the concerns of small-town Americans are
unimportant that's what the ad is saying
now at least it could be taken that way
easily I'm not necessarily saying that I
take it that way I don't take offense to
it and honestly I get kind of sick of
all the sucking up the
Mount America that candidates do and I
say that as somebody who lives in a
small town I live in a very small town
myself and I like living in a small town
but I don't need the constant thing a
small town America or the you know I
just I don't need it just shut up I know
I know it's pandering its patronizing it
is a it is a version of Sigourney Weaver
saying all women are superheroes I don't
you know if I if I was a woman which I
get which I could be as far as you know
I want to hear that I don't need some
celebrities you're a superhero let me
give you a star here's a sticker I don't
need that from candidates I don't need
you're a great small-town America we
love you but that being said so I I
don't need the the sucking up but but to
be condescending and dismissive on the
other end of the spectrum is definitely
not the right strategy okay and that
seems like that's what the Biden's doing
here or again it's very easy to spin it
that way and that's exactly what Buddha
judge did because he liked it or not is
a smart politician and so you give him
an ad like this this is a godsend this
is exactly the kind of attack he wants
so his campaign responded and said at
this moment the American people are
crying out for something completely
different from this classic Washington
style of politics while Washington
politics trivializes what goes on in
communities like South Bend South Bend
residents who now have better jobs
rising income a new life in their City
don't think their lives are a Washington
politicians punchline Pete's
on-the-ground experience as mayor
turning around a Midwestern industrial
city is exactly why he's running for
president the vice president's decision
to run this ad speaks more to where he
currently stands in this race than it
does about Pete's perspective as a mayor
and veteran right and that's that's a
good response and and one that Biden
walked right into it's I think that
response
completely neutralizes the ad and and so
that's but Biden is a is at this point
one of the least talented politicians
we've seen in a long time you just has
no sense of anything not just him but
his campaign team whoever put this ad
together
not to mention Biden is taking credit
for stuff that he didn't even do vice
presidents are about as decorative as
the lights under those bridges in fact
more decorative because the lights under
the bridges that's there for a reason
it's to stop boats from running into
them at night so that's kind of a
practical reason for that vice
presidents aren't stopping boats from
running into bridges they're not doing
anything they're glorified first ladies
they take off
they'll take on the position of
president if the president dies but if
he doesn't then they don't get credit
for doing the job by proxy they didn't
do anything so when Biden says I
negotiated deals and passed Obama care
what he should be saying is I smiled on
camera next to the people who negotiated
deals and passed Obama care not that the
deals or you know sending billions of
dollars to Iran in cash or assigning a
passing Obama care that's nothing to be
proud of first of all but it doesn't
matter anyway because he didn't do that
stuff and this is all to say nothing of
the awkward fact that Obama hasn't even
endorsed by Dhin so he goes on and on
about Obama his experience with Obama
well it's there's a there's a there's a
pretty conspicuous silence here from
from Obama on this so it's like if I'm
trying to get a job and I'm bragging to
the interviewer that I was really good
friends with the company's old boss and
then and then the interviewer says I
keep hitting my own fear then the
interview no the interviewer says like
oh okay well is he on your list of
references what oh no no I didn't put
him on on the list I he doesn't want to
be a reference or or actually endorse me
for the position but but trust me he
thinks I did a great job he told me he
told me I could tell you that that he
thinks I did a great job you don't have
to ask him you can't call him up anyway
it's early he's sleeping oh we could
just call him in the afternoon
no you can't call me after New Year
you'll be sleeping in - he's in a coma
turns out actually I forgot to mention
he's a boating accident ran into a jet
skier very very tragic so just take my
word for it though so there's the the
awkward silence they're not that of
course taking credit for things you
didn't do is pretty common political
strategy so I don't think that's gonna
hurt him very much but attacking the
from his perspective small or
unimportant priorities of small-town
America not a great strategy
another thing that's probably not a
great strategy though I enjoy it as a
viewer is Biden's penchant for insulting
his potential voters to their faces and
he's been doing this a lot recently and
really these are this is the only time I
ever like him anymore when these videos
pop up of him rental insulting his
voters and calling them names and it
happened again over the weekend here he
is at a recent campaign stop yet again
launching into an insult against a voter
who made the mistake of asking him a
question watch this so how do you
explain the performance in Iowa and what
should the voters believe that you can
win the national election it's a good
question number one I was a democratic
caucus there been no caucus no you
haven't
you're lying Dogface pony-soldiers you
said you were but now you got to be
honest I'm gonna be honest with you it
was a little bit confusing in Iowa
number one but let's assume it was all
everything was exactly right in Iowa the
idea that you come in with about half
the can half the delegates that the
leaders come in with in Iowa does not
necessarily say how you're gonna win
Pennsylvania how you gonna win Michigan
we're by the way the the black caucus of
the Michigan Legislature endorsed me in
spite of all of this work but the unions
have endorsed me in spite of all this
etcetera you can't win
lying dog faced pony soldier
I don't even know what that means I have
no idea what that means but it's a great
insult I want to go around calling
people that now I'm waiting for an
opportunity to call someone a lying dog
faced Pony soldier but probably not a
great thing to say to your voters
especially a woman who you just called
dog faced with and all she did was ask a
really fair respectful question but it's
hysterical I I gotta say I love it I
want to go to a Biden campaign event
just to be roasted by him I think he
should drop out and just become an
insult comic you should do you should do
those roasts on Comedy Central that
should be his thing because he's good at
that alright more to talk about but
first a quick word from stamps calm
postage rates have gone up again and
thankfully those stamps calm eases the
pain with big discounts off post office
retail rates with stamps calm you save
55 cents off every first-class stamp and
up to 40% off shipping rates that's you
know that kind of savings it really adds
up after a while especially for small
businesses speaking of small towns small
businesses you know any any savings you
can do especially on something a routine
thing you need you need postage you need
stamps if you could save money on that
there's no reason not to do it plus
stamps calm is completely online which
saves you time so no more trips to the
post office you just go online you take
care of it and it's done stamps.com
brings all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
you're an online seller shipping out
products you're a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day no matter
what your volume is or how big your
operation or how small is stamps.com can
handle it with ease simply use your
computer to print US official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it to
once your mail is ready just hand it to
your mail carrier drop it in the mailbox
it's that simple you're done okay stamps
calm not only saves you time it saves
you money too with stamps calm you get
discounted postage rates that you can't
you can't get at the post office so
you're saving the time and you're saving
the money again there's no reason
to not do this right now my listeners
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Walsh that stamps
comm enter Walsh stamps comm enter Walsh
ok wanted to talk about this a couple
days ago a clip was posted of Gayle King
CBS journalist interviewing Lisa Lisa
Leslie who's a WNBA player and a
longtime friend of Kobe Bryant and in
the clip Gayle King asks Leslie about
Kobe's rape rape case back in 2003 let
me play that clip for you here it's been
said that his legacy is complicated
because of sexual assault charge which
was dismissed in 2003 2004 is it
complicated for you as a woman as a WNBA
player it's not complicated for me at
all even if there's a few times that
we've been at a club at the same time
Kobe's not the kind of guy never been
like you know at least go get that girl
or tell her or send her this I have
other NBA friends that are like that
Kobe's he was never like that I just
never see have ever seen him being the
kind of person that would be do
something to violate a woman or be
aggressive in that way that's just not
the person that I know but Lisa you
wouldn't see it though as his friend you
wouldn't see it and that's possible
mm-hmm I just it's just I just don't I
just don't believe that and I'm not
saying things that had happened I just
don't believe that things didn't happen
with force is it even a fair question to
talk about it
considering he's no longer with us and
that it was resolved or is it really
part of his history I think that the
media should be more respectful at this
time it's like if you had questions
about it you've had many years to ask
him that I don't think it's something
that we should keep hanging over his
legacy I mean he went to it went to
trial
yeah but the cases it was dismissed
because the victim in the case refused
to testify
so it was dismissed and I think that
that's how we should leave it now that
was taken from a longer interview that
covered the life and legacy of Kobe Kobe
Bryant and this was just one line of
questioning in an otherwise favorable
segment on Kobe Bryant but nonetheless
people freaked out accused king of
disrespecting Kobe's memory etc etc and
there were people issuing death threats
and everything as unfortunately we've
come to expect in these situations but
one of the people that issued a threat
of violence seemingly was Snoop Dogg who
had this to say about the interview gay
okay out-of-pocket for that way out of
pocket what do you gain from that I
swear to god we the worse we the worse
we expect more from you Gayle don't you
hang out with Oprah
why y'all attacking us we owe people you
ain't coming after Harvey Weinstein
asking them dumb questions I get sick of
y'all I want to call you what is it okay
if I call them one funky dog hit how
dare you try to toss my mother homeboys
reputation punk mother respect a family
and back off before we come ditch okay
hopefully we can all agree that this
kind of reaction is totally beyond the
pale and wrong and stupid and hopefully
we could also agree that Snoop Dogg
might be the most overrated person in
the history of the music industry my
six-year-old could write more
interesting lyrics than this guy but in
any case that aside it should be
generally agreed that threatening
violence and that sort of thing is
ludicrous and morally atrocious but I
don't want to talk about the most
extreme over reactions I want to talk
about the sort of general feeling that
people seem to have then after a famous
person dies or really after anybody dies
were immediately supposed to shove the
negative aspects of their lives into the
memory hole and
pretend it never happened and that must
actually be the position of Kings
critics considering she's a journalist
it's two weeks since his death she's
doing an interview she's talking about
Kobe Bryant and she mentions it for like
one minute in that interview people are
upset about it so I guess what they're
saying is that subject should not be
broached at all we should simply not
talk about it at all we should pretend
it never happened when we talk about
Kobe Bryant we and we talk about his
life okay so you can talk about when he
was a kid you could talk about when he
was minoo at high school you could go
through but but once you get to that
little episode you got a leapfrog right
over it and continue on on along that's
what people seem to be saying which is a
problem because it's not really a little
episode it's kind of a big it's kind of
a big episode and I'm not saying Kobe is
guilty I don't know I said a couple
weeks ago that there are good reasons to
doubt the accusations and and that's
true but there are also compelling
reasons to potentially believe them such
as the fact that the woman went to the
police basically right away she didn't
wait twenty years and then come out
about it she allegedly told a friend
right away about it she had bruising on
her on her that Kobe admitted was from
choking her she was bleeding and he
eventually paid her off it didn't go to
trial because she decided she didn't
want to testify which maybe that means
she was lying but it could also mean
that he's a beloved sports figure and
she's just a peon like you or me and she
knows that his high-powered defense team
is gonna tear her apart and eat her for
breakfast and bring all her skeletons
out of the closet and she doesn't want
to go through that so she backed out so
that could be it - we don't know we just
don't know did Kobe commit the rape that
I think that question is very much in
the air but it is unreasonable to
declare his innocence as if the case
against him was laughable like it was
against Kavanagh
and I've heard people say oh there's no
evidence there was no evidence against
him there was evidence first of all
somebody accusing you of a crime in and
of itself is evidence now I'm not saying
it's anything close to conclusive
evidence and depending on the
circumstances it might not be very good
evidence like with Cavanaugh but it may
say a witness in this case the victim
themselves saying this person did it
that is a piece of evidence that you
have to weigh against everything else
it's just like if you were accused of
murdering somebody else and they didn't
have a they didn't have you know any
physical evidence but they had a witness
saying I saw him do it that would be
evidence not enough to convict you but
it is evidence so it's saying there's no
evidence you can't really say that but
but also on top of that they had the
bruising they had they did have physical
evidence they had his own admission
about choking her okay and what does it
mean it means that maybe he raped a
woman maybe he didn't but maybe he did
at a minimum he was a serial adulterer
by his own admission that fact that he
had affairs doesn't completely
overshadow his achievements and his good
points but it is a fact about his life
it just is are we not supposed to deal
with that fact at all I'm not saying it
should be brought up in the eulogy or
during the memorial service and I myself
was critical of the people who
immediately within minutes of of the
death being reported were online
bringing it up and calling him a rapist
and so on and so forth that to me is
obviously inappropriate especially when
you consider it wasn't just him who died
it was his daughter it was eight other
people besides so too immediately within
minutes the first thing you're doing is
saying oh remember his rape case to me
obviously inappropriate but does that
mean we're never supposed to talk about
those things ever again we're supposed
to rewrite his life story his story you
know we're supposed to turn it into
something more palatable more
family-friendly because we're
uncomfortable with this detail and this
is what we do with death we lie we
ignore we
make posthumous alterations to people's
lives we canonize almost everybody who
dies not everyone and in this
determination can be a little arbitrary
right because there are some people who
die and for them the negatives are the
only things we remember you for example
he's not dead yet but what do you think
is gonna happen when AJ dies you think
people are gonna observe a respectable
silence about his murder trial no it's
gonna be the first thing it's gonna be
in the headlines right
accused murderer OJ Simpson dies that's
gonna be the headline that's gonna be
the main thing people talk about with
him but OJ Simpson was a sports legend
too he was an icon before the murder
charge he was he was not only an icon in
sports but after that in pop culture he
starred in movies he was a beloved
figure and and he was found not guilty I
think he was guilty but none of us can
ever really know yet for him I think we
all know it's gonna be different what
about when Paterno died the Penn State
rape scandal was very much at the
forefront of our discussion about him
even though he he he did this long very
long career and had done many great
things in the community and many great
things for the kids who played for him
but the main thing we talked about was
this so I think there's some
arbitrariness to this the people that we
decide after they die oh they're a saint
and that's all we're gonna say and then
there are other people who died and we
say okay well here's the one bad thing
they maybe did and that's the only thing
we're gonna talk about so it's pretty
arbitrary generally though with dead
people what we do is we we usually go to
the positive direction and we do these
rewrites these edits where it's not just
that we ignore the bad but we actually
implicitly deny that the bad ever
happened and with with famous people
this process can happen very fast and
and it could be very extreme to the
point that with someone like Kobe the
posthumous canonization and
sanctification and whitewashing goes way
way way overboard way overboard we go
remembering a great ballplayer to
suddenly we're talking about the dude
like he's Mother Teresa with ball
handling skills like he's basically a
basketball playing Mother Teresa
um I mean people who didn't even know
him go around talking about it he's a
great husband great family man which
maybe he was maybe he was but I mean I I
know most of us doll have no idea and
and and I mean and if he was a great
husband it was after the adultery and
the potential rape so maybe after that
he became a great maybe he did you know
I don't know but I just don't get how
people feel entitled after someone dies
they feel like well as long as I'm
saying something positive I can
basically lie about the person and I can
make up details that I couldn't possibly
know to be true as long as it's positive
I can do it and I can throw out I can
discard the bad things that I do know
about I just throw it out man I just
pretend it didn't happen and why you
know what's the point like I said we do
this with non famous people - many of us
have seen this process play out - closer
to home somebody died is someone close
someone who was definitely human you
know had serious flaws as all of us do
maybe someone who was a bit of a selfish
jerk if we're being honest or had had
that side to them maybe it's an older
person who in truth really wasn't the
greatest mother or the greatest father
actually was kind of self-absorbed
actually kind of neglected their kids
for for long periods of time was kind of
emotionally absent and then they died
and almost immediately in our
conversations they become someone who
bears no resemblance to the person who
really lived we start rewriting them
right it's not nearly a matter of
focusing on the good in the immediate
aftermath which which of course you're
gonna do and like I said in the eulogy
at the funeral in the hospital if the
person dies in hospital the things are
talking about it so in those immediate
moments and those emotionally charged
moments yeah
you're talking about the positive and
that's a normal thing to do but but the
problem is that's so often with death
when somebody dies we begin that
rewriting process not just in the
immediate aftermath but that's how it
stays forever in our memory we have
turned this person into someone that
they weren't I am you know I think we
shouldn't do this
we think we're respecting the dead when
we do this but we're not we're lying
would you respect a living person today
by telling lies about them by making up
facts about them by trying to improve
them by lying about them how is that
respect it's it's the opposite because
part of respecting something or someone
is to recognize it for what it is and
that's why respect has multiple
connotations we also talked about if
you're going for a walk in the woods in
Montana you should respect the bears
that are in Montana by bringing some
bear spray with you now respect here
means not admiration but recognition of
what a bear is what its presence means
well I think we should respect people
alive and dead in the same way
recognizing them for what they are or
what they were who they were who they
are letting them exist whether in
reality or in our memory authentically
we should pay them that respect of
letting them be who they are or who they
were in trying to remember them that way
it can be difficult of course with
people that are close to you but with
famous people it shouldn't be that hard
because we're not yeah yes we we they
were a part of our lives in some way but
but but only in a very distant kind of
life we had no real connection with them
all right so I you know with someone
like Kobe Bryant I guess my summarize I
don't see why why can't we say what's
wrong when talking about Kobe what's
wrong with saying great basketball
player legend of the game did a lot of
great things in the community his family
seems to have loved him his community
seems to have loved him
but he had a dark side and he was
credibly accused of rape and he was not
always a loyal husband yeah why can't it
be that yes that's not very neat so it's
not it's not a neat picture of a person
you can't wrap a nice bow on it and it's
hard when you when you when you
acknowledge that about someone it's hard
to turn them into into a historic hero
that could be worshipped and you could
build monuments to it's true but he's a
person that's how people are it's it's
really difficult most people are not
neat like that want to go to emails but
first a word from honey here's the thing
with honey they're trying to save you
money
that's all they want to do and there's
no reason to decline the invitation if
you shop online which we all do in the
year 2020 you got to have honey I think
it's it's a it's a must you know that
honey is the free online shopping tool
that automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your cart and
you know how great it feels to save but
how does it feel to save with honey is
the question well I think saving with
honey feels like hitting every green
light on your commute to work finishing
up the the podcast right as you walk
into work or getting stuck in the middle
seat on a plane but then the person in
the aisle doesn't show up and so you get
to move over just like that
it feels great in other words a little
small tiny victory remember also
Valentine's Day is coming up and it's
not too late to buy a gift online and of
course the very definition of love is to
buy gifts for someone at the last minute
so go ahead and do that but as you're
buying those gifts online for
Valentine's Day make sure to save some
money by using honey honey has found
it's over 18 million members over two
billion dollars in savings
did you know honey supports over 30,000
stores online including Macy's Target
Sephora Best Buy many more than that and
every day they're adding more so it's
only gonna get better using honey feels
pretty great think of it as a little
daily victory little savings sometimes
big savings you know plus it's free to
use and in
stalls in just a few seconds get honey
for free at join honey calm slash Walsh
let's join honey calm slash Walsh
alright let's go to emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com a lot of interesting ones I'm
just gonna read one email to wrap up
this conversation that I wasn't
expecting so much feedback and
participation in it but this this thing
about the the simulation theory the
theory that we're all living in a
simulation none of us are real or like
virtual reality we're not even that but
we're like video game characters
basically this is a theory that some
people have postulated and apparently it
has it has at least based on my inbox
right now it has a fair number of
advocates or at least not at if not
advocates at least people who take it
seriously and so we were talking about
that let me read one email from who was
this from from Matt says hi Matt I was
listening to your rebuttal of semen
simulation theory and could help but
feel like you missed the point a bit
boström postulates that one of the
following must necessarily be true one
the fraction of human level
civilizations that reach a post human
stage that is one capable of running
high fidelity ancestor simulations is
very close to zero or to the fraction of
post human civilizations that are
interested in running simulations of
their evolutionary history or variations
thereof is very close to zero or 3 the
fraction of all people with our kind of
experiences that are living in a
simulation is very close to one again
one of these must be true therefore your
criticism that the theory ignores
probability misses the mark as the
argument is entirely based on
probability your argument about Sims and
Mario and other videogame characters
doesn't work because the simulated
humans postulated in theory would be
designed by post humans but who
possessed technology far beyond our
comprehension we aren't talking about
some low powered a Nintendo or Xbox
where the goal is to just play a game
personally I find the first choice of
the three entirely possible humanity
just won't get to the stage where we are
able to do that because we'll be wiped
out by ourselves or others before
happens the second choice seems highly
unlikely to me if we get to a posthuman
stage where we have the technology to
run advanced ancestor simulations of
humans throughout history to find out
what makes them tick will almost
certainly do so because that is the
exploratory nature of humans and I see
no reason to assume that we will lose
that over time therefore if we do reach
the stage in our evolution or have
already reached that stage and we just
don't know it because we are in one of
their simulations the number of
simulated Minds will no doubt outnumber
the number of real Minds by a staggering
order of magnitude because of all the
different simulations people throughout
the world we were running therefore it
is probable that we were more likely
simulated than not assuming we aren't
going to be wiped out before creating
advanced simulation technology when
rogue and interviewed boström he was
unable to get past the question why
assume any of these three statements are
true keep in mind that one of these
three three statements has to be correct
this is not the same as assuming there's
a pink unicorn circling the earth or
something like that
thanks love the show okay so I basically
what you're saying is probability was
either we are simulated people and not
real or humanity's gonna be wiped out in
some sort of nuclear catastrophe or
something like that those are the two
those are the two possibilities that's
all we get rather rather grim I like it
I like grim I like grim so okay III I do
understand the point of the simulation
theory but maybe maybe my rebuttal was
was off in the weeds so let me try to
refocus more on the point so the the
argument is if I can simplify your that
there's this idea of a simulation that a
future Society might run simulating the
past so they can observe and see what it
was like and and maybe we are currently
in that simulation where our characters
in it and a future civilization is
watching us hoping that we don't catch
on or maybe hoping that we do I don't
know as bostrom says either society
never develops the ability to create the
simulation and thus we aren't in one or
it develops the ability and decides not
to and thus we aren't in one or society
develops the ability to create one and
does and thus
we might be in one okay well yes I agree
that those are the options but then
those are the options for any imaginary
technological ability that I might
conjure in my head I could do this with
literally anything you see the problem
for example I could say either society
never develops the ability to put dogs
in a dream state where they think
they're human and then imagine a human
life with human experiences and human
memories or it develops that ability it
decides not to or it develops that
ability and decides to do it in thus I
might actually be a dog in a laboratory
dreaming of a human existence that's you
have to admit right that those are the
options one of them must be true which
means you must admit that there's at
least a chance that we're all a bunch of
dogs dreaming man you can't prove you're
not that is theoretically technology
that could be developed or maybe I'm
just maybe I'm the only real dog and
you're all figments of my imagination
who knows now you could say that the
ancestor simulation is more likely than
the dog thing but why would you say that
I think that that to me seems utterly
arbitrary because they're both entirely
imaginary invented hypotheticals there
is no actual evidence for either there's
no reason to believe it as in you
haven't seen anything in your life for
which the best explanation of that
particular thing in isolation is the
simulation okay you've never experienced
in your life a single thing where you
could say okay the best explanation for
this phenomena is that we're in a
simulation everything you see and
experience can easily be explained by
your physical and real existence so
there just isn't any reason to think
that there's anything beyond that or or
it or that you know there isn't any
reason to postulate anything besides
that you exist physically and that's why
you're experiencing stuff and that's
another problem with the theory that the
simulation to be worth doing would have
to function exactly like real life right
which means you can't say that there's
something in your life that would be
best explained by the simulation because
if the simulation seems like a
simulation then there's no point to it
which means that even if we're in the
simulation there could never be any
reason to think we are by definition so
even if it's true by far the most
rational thing regardless is to still
assume that it isn't true which makes
the theory useless at best because if it
isn't true it has no explanatory power
and if it is true it has no explanatory
power that's the thing about a theory
so yeah an actual theory has to explain
something has to have explanatory power
as in you you know you come up with this
theory and now you're looking around the
world at stuff I'd say okay well this
makes sense now that's what a theory
does but by definition this simulation
hypothesis can have no explanatory power
because again if it does then that means
that it the simulation in some way seems
like a simulation which means it's a bad
simulation there's no point to it I mean
why would you have a simulation to see
how people operate it in the past if
they know they're in the simulation and
then that's gonna throw off the the
everything there's no point to doing it
right
also you still haven't explained how a
simulated being could have conscious
experiences and you can't just say well
technology will figure that out I mean
you can say that but it's it's literally
a deus ex machina it's it's you're
invoking some random unexplained machine
or tech to explain this massive hole in
your theory
how could a simulated being have inner
experience it would seem that it's
simulated being could not have inner
experience because inner experiences are
themselves in effect simulations your
brain organic matter this is the only
way we know how consciousness works your
brain organic matter takes bits of
information from reality reconstructs it
in your mind so that really we're all
sort of hallucinating all the time we're
all experiencing a hallucination every
second of the in effect because our
brain is reconstructing from all the
billions and trillions of bits
reconstructing this is how this is how
you know illusions and things work by by
by by manipulating what your brain
predicts so that means the simulated
beings would have themselves the
capacity to simulate we are then
simulated beings building simulations of
the simulation you see how absurd this
gets especially when there is no known
way even in theory to build such a
machine now we know of ways in theory to
travel across the galaxy even if we have
to use wormholes which are also
theoretical but so it but in theory we
understand how that could work
nobody even in theory could tell you how
it could work for a machine to create
simulated beings that have consciousness
because we're not even talking about
robots I mean you could sooner argue
that we're all a bunch of lifelike
robots so why not argue that you could
do the same exact thing with that and at
least robots are material now I still
think that putting consciousness in a
robot is impossible but the idea of
having consciousness sort of hovering in
the ether the with these simulated
beings we have no way in theory of doing
that one other thing if Humanity is
moving inexorably towards building
simulations with conscious experiences
which I don't think it is honestly I
think my dreaming dog theory is just as
likely but if it is then wouldn't the
simulation be headed in that direction
too so wouldn't the simulation build
simulations and then the simulations and
in the simulations would also build
simulations and then simulations in the
simulations would build simulations in a
simulator on and on and on
so maybe were the simulation of a
simulation of a simulation of a
simulation of a simulation of a
simulation of a simulation and maybe all
of this simulating is happening in the
mind of a dreaming dog maybe but there's
no reason to think any of this there's
no tangible evidence so that's my my
answer as fun as it is to think about at
least for me you know for me and you and
some people
it's fun to think about and talk about I
suspect I may be boring everyone else to
death so I will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]